650 millions d'euros partis en fumée
plus de 250 attaques de commissariat
plus de 4000 interpellations 2023 aura
été l'année qui a connu les pires
émeutes depuis mai
[Musique]
1968 il est rentré oh
[__] 15 un coup de feu retenti
l'auteur est l'un de ses
policiers au volant le conducteur naë un
adolescent de 17 ans conduisant sans
permis il meurt selon le policier il
aurait refusé d'obtempérer lors d'un
contrôle
routier la garde à vue et la mise en
examen de l'agent de police n'y font
rien rapidement des individus appel à
venger l'adolescent dès la fin de
l'après-midi nanter et les villes
voisines mais aussi CIT de Colmar Mantel
jolie Bordeaux et Marseille sont
investis par des émetiers des barricades
sont érigé puis
incendié la cité Pablo picassoù réside
la famille de naë se transforme en champ
de
bataille émeut à Nanterre dans plusieurs
villes des haut de SC et en sc
Saint-Denis des dizaines de policiers
sont blessés le bilan de la nuit annonce
l'ampleur du
soulèvement
[Musique]
2000 policiers et gendarmes sont
déployés en ce 28 juin 2023 les heures
débordent des cités des quartiers plus
calmes sont eux-mêm touchés le nombre
d'interpellations explose ce reste de ma
voiturees enfants
ded la République est touché avec des
attaques de commissariat caserern de
gendarmerie mais aussi des mairies et
même des
écoles les rues sans bras incendie
magasins pillé et les violences touchent
Paris même dans les arrondissements
Nord valde mararne valdoise et son
Occitanie les émeutes commencent à faire
Tage d'huile et s'étendent à toute la
France c'est la journée la plus intense
une marche blanche à l'appel de la mer
de Naël se déroule à Nanterre l'ambiance
reste calme sauf qu'à peine la marche
àchevé la cité Pablo Picasso se soulève
de nouveau et nanter redevient le
théâtre de scène de Guera dès la fin de
l'après-midi les forces de l'ordre se
préparent à une nouvelle tempête hier il
y avait 9000 policiers gendarmes
mobilisés dont 2000 sur la plaque
parisienne j'ai décidé qui 40000
policiers gendarmes ce soir et cette
nuit mobilisé dont 5000 en PL
parisiennes et des moyens technique et
technologique important les pillages et
les actes de vandalisme continu à clamar
dans les haut de scène un tramou est
incendiier la présidente de la région
Valérie PC annonce la suspension des
transports après
21h face à la propagation des émeutes
plusieurs communes annoncent
l'instauration
couvrefeu
l'usage massif des messageries crypté et
des réseaux sociaux rend obsolètes les
leçons apprises par les autorités lors
des émeutes de 2005 organisé mobile les
regroupements deviennent
imprévisibles le nombre d'interpellés
explose des centaines de policiers sont
blessés des milliers de véhicules sont
brûlés il n'y a plus assez de pompiers
pour éteindre
l'incendie
cela met en cause la
sécurité la
moralité les pillages se multipli
partout en France et plus
particulièrement en région
parisienne centres commerciaux magasins
locaux se transforme en champ de
bataille comme à Paris Bordeaux Lyon ou
Marseille
la violence à l'encontre des forces de
l'ordre monte d'un cran avau envelin un
homme tire au fusil à pompe quatre
policiers finissent à l'hôpital les
émetiers attaquent carrément les
policiers à la voiture
bélier le concert de men Farmer prévu
depuis des mois est
annulé pour des raisons de sécurité
évidentes pour
t la situation semble échapper à tout
contrôle lorsque des groupuscules
d'extrême droite sortent affronter les
émeetiers dans la rue à Paris Angers et
l'Orient leur objectif cassé de la
racaille des particuliers sont obligés
de se défendrex même quand leurs
domiciles sont attaqués par les
aimetiers
[Musique]
à la fin de la journée des dizaines de
commissariats et gendarmerie ont été
attaqués des milliers de véhicules
réduits en cendre à ce stade deux fois
plus de policiers ont été blessés qu'en
[Musique]
c'est dans la nuit du 1er au 2 juillet
que le domicile de Vincent jeambrin
maire de la rose est attaqué par une
voiture bélier en feu sa femme et ses
deux enfants ont été
blessés j'ai peur du monde dans lequel
grandiront n mais j'ai encore de
l'espoir au momentù je m'exprime devant
vous j'ai l'espoir et de la force et
c'est notamment le courage de mon épouse
courage de ma femme qui me permet d'être
là devant vous et de vous dire une chose
simple on n pas
battu se le bilan des émeutes est sans
précédent des milliers de véhicules
d'écoles de mairie ont été dégradé ou
incendié plus de 4000 individus sont
interpelés trois fois plus de personnes
sont condamnées à des peines de prison
ferme qu'en 2005
[Musique]
nous attendons des mesures sur la
politique de la ville puis aucune
orientation de la part du gouvernement
depuis trop longtemps je suis
extrêmement déçu en plus d'être exténué
parce que ça fait 5 jours qu'on dort 2
he par nuit à faire des patrouilles dans
la ville pour essayer d'aider la police
nationale la première réponse c'est
l'ordre le calme c'est la Concorde et
ensuite c'est de travailler sur les
causes profondes de ce qui est
advenu fin 2023 une question revient en
boucle verra-t-on pire en
[Musique]